Hey guys! How's things going?
So a lot of you guys ask me quite often,
What iPhone case do I have.
And of course, a lot of you are well-awared,
that I did get the Jet Black iPhone,
But you are confused, in a lot of videos
As in 'Why it looks like I had a Matte Black iPhone."
So to start things off, the case that I'm currently using
On my phone, is just the basic silicone case from Apple.
Nothing too special.
But the case you guys probably saw on my phone,
And got confused, is this case.
It's inside here, called the Peel case.
This is not sponsored
I'm not gonna say that this case is the reason that
I shattered my phone,
Two times, in 24 hours
I'm reckless, yes.
I was holding my dog, and I had my phone,
And he pulls me, and my phone
Fell flat on its face.
Now usually with any other normal cases
They have a little bit of a lip on them
So it will kinda protect your screen a little bit
But the Peel case, is actually so awesome
Because it doesn't have a lip on it.
It basically just conforms to your iPhone
And it's basically like, you have nothing on it.
It's like, your phone is naked.
So after I got my screen replaced,
I put my case back on.
But I dropped it so hard,
That I cracked the case,
And also, cracked the...
Little bottom part of my phone here.
So the only case that I've left,
Was this black one that I previously been using.
Another issue that I have, is when I'm flying
my DJI Mavic is
I can't really fit this phone,
Plus a case, into it.
But with this little guy,
It is, so incredibly thin,
That it kinda protects the back of your screen.
Now if you're reckless, I do not recommand
getting this, but if you're
Not too reckless, then this case is so perfect.
They also have the jet black one too but...
I really wouldn't recommend because
It smuge a lot and it scratch a lot.
I thought that it will kinda make my phone
Look like it was Jet Black.
It did. But the Matte Black Peel case works great.
Flip for instructions? Okay.
Since I have a little accident,
I saw that they also have something
It's a glass edge-to-edge screen protector,
I haven't try this out yet, but I think this
Might solve my problem.
Oh! It gives me a little cloth
And alcohol prep pack
Oh Yeah!
Good, look at that.
It basically looks exactly like
Your iPhone.
So this just go right on top of your phone.
So I'll assemble the case, and put this on,
and hopefully, I won't crack my phone again.
'Peel off the plastic carefully'. Oh god. OK.
Alcohol it up, preping up for surgery~
Remove any remaining dust particle.
I'm so nervous., I'm not gonna line this up well.
Did I do a good job?
Looks really good.Like you honestly can't tell
That there's something on here. At all. It's so good.
I'm impressed.
Now, I'm gonna put this cover on.
Guess I'm just gonna use my alcohol pack and,
Clean the back of this up too. Slob.
So I feel like the combination of this things
Will alleviate the incidents that happened before.
Here we go. I mean, this is so thin.
Like look at this, it's crazy how thin it is.
Now it makes my phone looks like it's Matte Black.
Which you can hardly even tell, that I've anything on it.
It's great it looks like my phone isn't crack anymore.
So here's gonna be the real test.
Will I be able to fit this, nice and comfortably into
The DJI Mavic controller.
Here we go~
It still fits, quite well.
And it's much easier than any other cases.
So this is cool.
Oh god.
This is why we can't, have nice things,
in this house.
It fits, oh wait, you can see
there's like a little bubble there.
It didn't do a very good job
These steps are extremely important,
Let's clean you guys while we're at it.
Well I'll keep you guys posted if you follow me
On twitter, @iJustine,
or Instagram, @iJustine.
You don't see me post anything about shattered phone,
Then you'll know, that this has been successful.
Yes, I'm very happy. It looks great.
It feels, I mean it still thinner then this phone,
like I can still probably fits my phone inside of this case.
Because it's so thin.
So when you guys questioned,
What case I have, and why I don't have a Jet Black
phone, I do, still have the Jet Black iPhone,
It's just covered in the Peel case.
This is great. I'm super excited and I've said that,
I already said it many times.
Well, thank you guys so much for watching,
I'll put a link in the description where you guys can
check out these cases, they're pretty cool,
I'm a big fan, like I said,
I did shattered my phone twice, with them.
So, if that happens to you,
don't say I didn't warn you,
Which is why I recommend getting this glass cover,
I feel like this is gonna really protects your phone.
If you do drop it, face down.
Like I did, Nothing is full-proof.
Except those otter boxes, cause those things
are beyond intense,
Let me know if there's anything else you think
It's pretty cool, you guys might wanna check out.
And maybe I'll check it out.
I'll see you guys in the next video.Bye!
(Preview of previous video)